connor overton is making his first major
league start big league debut came
earlier this season with the toronto
blue jays short time ago that was
overton just taking them out now he's
ready in this bouncing ball to the
shortstop newman and a little pick in
the dirt by moran
schrock swings and shoots one through
the vacated left side a base hit shrock
around first thought about second slams
on the brakes about a third of the way
to second and hangs on tight at first
with a one-out single
wow tied him up there the off-speed
pitch and he gets the strikeout connor
overton
oh he had a strikeout and now a walk
and overton has a couple of strikeouts
his first big league start
tyler malley for the reds saw the ball
really well maui is coming off an outing
against the cardinals six really clean
outing six innings couple of runs those
two runs came on a home run by yachty or
molina looking for win number 12.
and right up the middle that has been
just his signature move keep ryan hayes
just gets up there and whacks it dead
central and mali strikes out
suzugo that is the bread and butter from
alley that four seamer up
india misplays it you can see him look
towards second
and not look the ball into his glove
it's first and second
former covers
pick off he got him malley and farmer
slice down reyes at second base two outs
pitch and moran grounds it weakly to the
right side it'll be farmer handling it
on the second base side of the bag the
shortstop throws to first in time moran
is out the pirates are done in the first
here's gamble to lead it off hitting at
248.
and i base hit to center field for ben
gamel to lead off the bottom of the
second and there goes gammel
oh gammel
has been on the other end of missed hit
and runs and has cost us reason why he
has been caught stealing
six of seven times but this time he'll
get a stolen base
wow
how about that
that got in the kitchen oh
i'm way in the kitchen i'm curious if we
have a super slow man one i'd like to
see where that hit oh
india fires home stevenson tag gamal is
out
and slow to get up
india gets it fires and
even though the throw is low stevenson
takes it and
basically gets out there very legally
and prevents the runner from getting
anywhere close to the plate swing and a
foul tip stevenson holds on to strike
three and down on strikes hoy park mali
able to work around the leadoff single
here in the pirates second scoreless
game go to the top of the third inning
here's the one in india he swings and
launches one to center routine for
reynolds a few steps shy of the track he
makes a catch one out
and an easy comebacker
two outs he is making it look easy
well that'll settle things
i think he's gonna go three
three scoreless tremendous
innings for connor overton
ben gamel now singled and stole second
and gamble again
a base hit up the middle pirates have
four hits two each by
key brian hayes and ben gamel the
one-two
bouncing ball should be two india fields
flips to farmer that's one over tovato
not in time newman can run a little bit
india
lead man farmer in time double play dp
lane
mallio leadoff
and mali
and the catch made by tsutsugo
nice play he's had his
struggles at times out there but very
fine play on that one
nice catch
he's he's adjusted he's he's worked on
that
right field his first game out there he
did struggle potts ready to go in the
one-two of swinging wall weakly hit on
the second base park fields throws the
first and got him by a half step
and this one's tapped on toward first
base right near the bag moran will take
it there for the final out nice inning
one two three go the reds
sutsugo third time now against mali and
tsutugo sends a high fly ball deep
center field akiyama's back and on the
warning track just in front of the wall
he makes the catch
to the right of dead center
and a base hit for someone other
than hayes for gammel and it's
ryan reynolds
moran
takiyama
there's a ground ball farmer fields it
the shortstop of backhand pick looks to
second throws just in time to get gamble
on a close play at first
tyler stevenson will lead it off for
cincinnati
stevenson cranks one to right
and that one off the fencing a stand-up
double
from tyler stevenson and that's a spark
in the seventh
and he walks here ponce careful
to be down in the zone largely in gives
farmer first base he squares drops it
down
and
a fair ball that's going to move the man
up the first career sacrifice for shogo
akiyama second and third one down and
destroyable cabrera is going to hit here
cabrera
camel makes the catch tag at second and
third to shield scores sac fly rbi reds
on the board one to nothing i got a
pitch out over the plate and he knows if
he can just get that ball into the
outfield it's going to be enough to get
the liner to shields home from third
base
the pirates will bring on a new pitcher
here in the eighth inning it is
left-hander jason shreve
chasing comes in his 50th appearance
with a 3-1 record and a 2.77 era
strikes out aquino
aquino a strikeout victim to start the
reds eighth inning
and now to center field
lazy fly ball
two outs
joey vado a walk he's over two
bottle to the left center that's gonna
get down that's gonna get all the way to
the wall joey vado a two out double
never an easy out vato gets a breaking
ball that just kind of spins up there
though and stays about thigh high stays
behind it two and two
there's hayes
and keep ryan hayes will lead off for
the pirates in the bottom half of the
eighth inning as jason street pitches a
scoreless top half
right-hander michael gibbons will come
out of the red's bullpen this is his
50th overall appearance three and three
with a two-point
9-1 era his combined numbers with the
rockies and the reds
swing at the base of three pitch k
gave one good pitch to hit that was the
first pitch of the ab and after that it
got really tough on him here's the 3-2
and that's outside now the walk to
gamble
and the pirates have the winning run
coming to the plate in the person of
kevin newman another 3-2 pitch due kevin
newman again gamble takes off and it's
first and second with one away not even
close to a strike in a crucial situation
and hits a fly ball here will be the
second out or should be
and gamma will tag and
that might not be all that meaningful
but
ball of the dirt gets away
he's 90 feet away two outs
struck him out
gibbons blows it by him and the reds
post a combined six hit shutout they
blank the pirates one to nothing